y le esperaban que el plazo no llegara
nunca este miércoles los profesionales
de la salud que no se hayan vacunado
contra el cubil 19 serán suspendidos la
decisión pretende frenar la enfermedad y
evitar que los hospitales se saturen
pero los sindicatos y muchos
trabajadores dicen que la vacunación no
debería ser obligatoria
como profesionales de la salud sabemos
cómo tratar y proteger a nuestros
pacientes pero desde hace un tiempo
intentan hacernos sentir culpables
cuando durante la primera oleada nos
trataron como dioses de actuación y
sueño aunque con fútbol 300.000
trabajadores sanitarios perderán su
sustento sentimos que nos están
sacrificando y que a nadie le importa la
misión general los hospitales de parís
dicen que la proporción de profesionales
no vacunados es pequeña aún así si ya no
pueden ir a trabajar esto supondría una
mayor presión para los hospitales que
carecen de personal el personal
profesional o estamos hablando de
100.000 trabajadores del hospital y ya
hay recortes por todas partes se
imaginan perder y mil personas entre las
principales razones por las que algunos
no quieren vacunarse están el miedo a
los efectos secundarios y la sospecha de
que las vacunas no sean lo
suficientemente
eficaces
hemos tenido pacientes totalmente
vacunados que tuvieron que ser
hospitalizados en unidades de cuidados
intensivos esos porque estaban
contaminados con la variante de
la gran mayoría de los trabajadores de
la salud están vacunados incluso varios
escépticos lo hicieron ya que no podían
prescindir de su sueldo lo que no está
claro es si los que aún no recibieron
dosis o podrán regresar a los hospitales
dentro de unas semanas